Хей хочеш вступати до правтеху підготуй
такі документи заява у ній каже обрану
професію та місце проживання А ще
свідоцтво про базову або загальну
середню освіту медичну довідку копії
документів які надають право на пільги
Якщо такі є та 6 фотографій розміром 3х4
для зарахування тобі потрібно особисто
пред'явити документ що підтверджує
громадянство та документ що посвідчує
особу чи є спеціальний статус Якщо маєш
посвідку на постійне чи тимчасове
проживання в Україні або статус біженця
більше про вступну кампанію шукай на
сайті мон у розділі професійно-технічна
освіта а також на сторінках Міністерства
у соціальних мережах приклади руку до
самореалізації вступає до профтеху
[музика]